[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
tengo un amigo llamado benjamín jordan
el tienes record guinness por haber sido
la primera persona en cruzar canadá de
oriente a occidente volando en un
parapente motorizado
un día me propuso hacer una película
sobre el parapente me dijo rafa tienes
que volar en esta película
yo le dije no espérate benjamin estás
loco yo no puedo volar le tengo miedo a
las alturas
siempre he pensado que entre más cerca
del suelo es mejor por eso no tengo
piernas
pero él me dijo que este proyecto era
para recaudar fondos y ayudar a niños
también explicó que el parapente es lo
más cercano a cómo vuelan las aves
que se usa en corrientes de aire
caliente para elevarse y del resto se
planea
me explico también que morelia donde
íbamos a volar
era el punto más seguro y estable
climatológicamente hablando
morelia tenía estadística de cero en
accidentes
la verdad es que no sé cómo me deje
convencer pero accedí
entonces llegamos a morelia 20 am y me
presento al look a lo que es el chico
con el cual yo iba a volar
cuando ya llegamos al punto de despegue
benjamin me dice mira rafa allá está la
pista de aterrizaje de emergencia yo vi
una cosa terrible espantosa en una selva
con matorrales crecidos maizales así
altísimos yo me asusté elegí eso me
explicaron que se encontraba en esas
condiciones de mal mantenimiento porque
nunca se había usado
yo dije
entonces
cuando estaban poniéndome todo el equipo
del parapente
yo me di cuenta que desde que accedí
hasta ese momento yo estaba muerto de
miedo
pero por dentro me hacía a mí mismo
hazlo por los niños hazlo por los niños
así despegamos
sentí un momento de satisfacción muy
grande porque lo estaba logrando estaba
volando el objetivo se estaba cumpliendo
los expertos dicen
que en su conjunto los miedos
inciden en el 5% de la población mundial
es decir que de cada 10 personas media
persona tiene un miedo hace años las
matemáticas no fallan
o lo podemos ver como que una de cada 20
personas padece de algún tipo de fobia
el miedo es una condición psicológica
que en situaciones normales
genera respuestas fisiológicas como
acelera el ritmo del metabolismo aumenta
la presión arterial
la adrenalina la glucosa la tensión
muscular y la dilatación de las pupilas
pero puede llegar a niveles muy altos
y has tenido la gran mayoría de los
siguientes síntomas hay que tener
cuidado cuando llegue a niveles elevados
puedes llegar a sentir adormecimiento en
las manos dolor en el pecho
hiperventilación terror fuera de control
y problemas al respirar
si te ha pasado eso tu nivel de miedo es
muy elevado y necesitas acudir a un
especialista para que te dé un
tratamiento
en un estudio que se hizo en eeuu se
demostró que solamente el 8% de las
personas de los pacientes
acude un tratamiento psicológico y
psiquiátrico
hay que tener cuidado es muy poco esa
estadística pero bueno ya
aclarado lo anterior de que lo que yo
voy a hablar es en condiciones normales
ahora te pregunto
cuál es tu miedo le tienes miedo al
fracaso le tienes miedo a la oscuridad
le tienes miedo a la soledad
le tienes miedo a la muerte
como comentamos hace unos momentos el
miedo es un sistema de defensa en
nuestra mente que nos evita a toda costa
lastimarnos sentir dolor
los miedos podemos aprenderlos a través
de la experiencia de lo que se nos
enseña a veces tenemos miedos que ni
siquiera son nuestros
y como toda la vida el miedo tiene un
lado positivo y un lado negativo
el lado negativo es que el miedo puede
evitar que hagas cosas que sabes que
puedes hacer
porque el miedo te paraliza en su lado
positivo el miedo puede plantearse en
una realidad
se puede decir que si quieres aventarte
de un avión a 10.000 pies pues necesitas
equipamiento especial de otro modo
morirás el miedo puede salvarnos la vida
imaginemos el miedo como una serpiente
tiene dos extremos cola y cabeza si tú
agarras la serpiente por la cola ésta se
puede volver hacia ti y te morder a
pero si le agarras por la cabeza puedes
tener control de la serpiente así pasa
con nuestros miedos si los tomamos del
lado correcto podemos controlarnos y los
pasos para controlar el miedo son los
siguientes paso número 1 saber el origen
de tu miedo
como habíamos comentado el miedo es un
sistema
que evita el dolor
hay dos tipos de dolor el dolor físico y
el dolor emocional
por ejemplo la acrofobia que ocupa el
lugar número 8 de las 10 fobias más
comunes
es el miedo a caer y lastimarte o que en
esa caída mueras dolorosamente es decir
es un miedo al dolor físico
o por ejemplo está la glosó fobia que es
el miedo hablar en público
y lo padecemos el 95% de la población
aquí es tener miedo a hacer el ridículo
a quedar mal a que te juzgue
por lo tanto lástima en tu ego y es un
dolor emocional
así que es bueno saber el origen de tu
miedo a qué dolor si es emocional o es
físico porque si sabremos qué
herramienta utilizar es como por ejemplo
saber la diferencia entre un clavo y un
tornillo para cada uno se usa una
herramienta distinta el paso número 2
es detenerte mantener la calma y pensar
lo mejor conocido como contar hasta 10
con esto
evitamos el impulso
mantenemos la calma y evitamos que
nuestra mente emocional actúe
porque de otro modo la mente emocional
despierta tu instinto de supervivencia y
entonces podemos empezar a actuar como
animales podemos paralizarnos y para ser
muertos así como la zarigüeya actúa
frente al peligro
por eso es necesario calmarse y dejar
que nuestra mente racional actúe y
analice la situación
que de hecho es el paso número 3
analizar y decidir cómo actuar ante cada
situación hay muchísimas cosas por hacer
una de ellas es que podemos buscar una
motivación que nos ayude a seguir a
pesar del miedo en mi caso era decir
hazlo por los niños
otra ayuda es
informarte el informarte te ayuda a qué
puedas dejar de pensar en los peligros
potenciales y entonces darte cuenta de
que no hay ningún peligro o esos
peligros son mínimos
de esta manera es como se controlan los
miedos pero qué pasa
si tu miedo se hace realidad en pleno
vuelo lo que me dice rafa estamos
teniendo problemas no encuentro una
corriente de aire caliente que nos
vuelva elevar y estamos descendiendo
poco a poco y ya estamos muy cerca de la
copa de los árboles voy a tener que
aterrizar de emergencia
con su experticia logramos aterrizar en
la pista de emergencia claro que por el
mal mantenimiento tuvimos una caída muy
aparatosa yo salí volando por un lado
luque por el otro
afortunadamente no tuve ningún golpe
fuerte nada más tuve un raspón
en ese momento yo estaba muerto de miedo
y me dijeron rafa todavía no terminamos
la película tienes que volver a volar
[Risas]
dando cosas que
entonces yo les dije no están locos yo
no lo voy a volver a hacer subimos y
pasó un rato me dejaron tranquilo pasó
un rato y después de gaulle uca y me
dijo rafa no quiero que te quedes con
esta mala impresión del parapente dale
una segunda oportunidad y lo vas a
disfrutar
me puse a pensar que lo peor ya había
pasado
y que si le daba una segunda oportunidad
lo peor que podía pasar era pasármelo
bien
y efectivamente me armé de valor
emprendimos el vuelo de nuevo y disfrute
el atardecer más hermoso de mi vida
cuando un miedo no se ha hecho realidad
es como una cerca de madera que puedes
brincar cuando quieras usando las
herramientas antes señaladas pero cuando
tu miedo se hace realidad se convierte
en el mismísimo muro de berlín pero
recuerden que ese muro también cayó y
para derrumbar ese muro existen tres
pasos el primer paso es us es aceptación
es decir que sí
a veces las cosas te pueden salir muy
mal
que la ley de murphy es cierta
y que si algo puede salir mal saldrá mal
por eso hay que tener precaución tomar
en cuenta todos los riesgos
y el segundo paso es resiliencia
saber que detrás de ese muro enorme
existen la posibilidad
de disfrutar la vida de ser felices
de aprender de los errores de limpiarte
las lágrimas
de emprender el vuelo nuevamente y
disfrutar de un atardecer maravilloso
como lo hacen las aves volando
podemos darnos la oportunidad de ser
personas valientes
y que es una persona valiente
es aquella que a pesar de su miedo
disfruta su maravillosa vida
[Aplausos]
gracias